Film Courage: How important was it for you
to make a feature film before you turned thirty?
Chris von Hoffmann, horror writer/director:
It was very important.
I’ve been wanting to make a feature at 19
I was trying to make a feature, at 22-23 I
was trying to make a feature (they were all
different movies) and then at 24 I was trying
to make another feature.
At 25 I spent a year trying (that one got
the furthest).
And we had a sizzle reel that we shot, a pitch
package, we had a business, we had a script,
we had a lot of stuff packaged for that movie.
But we would have people come on, they would
fall off, we just couldn’t get…it was
like a $200,000 contract…it probably need
like $200,000, it was like 25 locations (a
lot of them were interior), it was another
desert movie.
And I think I took a lot of that stuff and
put it inside of DRIFTER, like a lot of the
thematic of that movie and just made DRIFTER
a little bit more cheaper and a little bit
more accessible.
I spent a year on that movie throughout 2013.
Some people responded to the script, some
people didn’t.
Some people just didn’t get it.
Because it wasn’t very plot heavy, it was
a very character driven story, this really
kind of like whacked out cross-country story,
sort of like it was from California to Texas.
And
at a certain point I was like “I’ve got
to drop this on.”
And I made a couple shorts out of frustration
to be creatively stimulated.
And then I was like 27 when I decided to just
jump into it with DRIFTER and I was like just
set the dates, I got locked in dates.
I was just like I’m going to bang this thing
out.
At least I can have a movie with a feature
film run time, I can at least have a feature
under my belt.
It might not be amazing but I have a feature
technically.
So that was just very important to me to make
a feature film as soon as possible.
But it’s like there is aways someone out
there that made that feature before you.
Soderbergh was 25 or 26, Scorsese 26, there’s
always someone out there to beat you to the
punch.
Because I spent a lot of time acting so I
was focusing on that for awhile.
Yes, it was very, very important for me to
make a feature before I was 30, very important
to me.
Film Courage: Did you crowdfund for DRIFTER?
Chris: Um, yeah…we tried.
It just wasn’t successful at all.
It was like embarrassedly unsuccessful.
I realize that it just wasn’t the kind of
movie that…I mean I’ll never do that kind
of stuff again.
I really kind of feel better for ever really
starting that campaign.
I didn’t feel like that movie leant itself
to that kind of campaign very well because
all I was trying to make was a really psychological
disturbing cannibal movie and we didn’t
have any hook.
Some of the people were familiar with a couple
shorts that I made, we didn’t have any hook.
We didn’t any hook.
We didn’t have any big genre actor attached,
it wasn’t based on a field game or a graphic
novel or anything.
It was just what it was and there was just
no hook to it.
There were some nice side donators but a lot
of it was personal sacrifice.
I mean I don’t know if I recommend that
to a lot of filmmakers to do that and a lot
of filmmakers have a lot of success crowdfunding,
and I just don’t even know how they do that?
I never understood the mystery of Indiegogo
and Kickstarter, I just don’t get it.
I don’t understand how they get this money,
I don’t.
So I’ve never had any success with any crowdfunding
campaigns.
I’ve tried a couple including that one and
I’ve just never had any success with it.
It’s like I’m not going to just like drop
this.
Especially at that time I needed to make a
feature.
And I just lived really cheaply, lived really
uncomfortably so I could save money and just
put it all towards the movie.